America's third richest person is Larry Ellison, the founder of Oracle.
Ellison stepped down as the CEO of the company in 2014...
...but he remains the company's chairman and its Chief Technology Officer.
The other oracle on the list, he hails from Omaha.
Warren Buffet, number two on the rich list this year.
Berkshire Hathaway took big steps into the aerospace sector...
...with its acquisition of Precision Castparts, which reported a 1.5 billion-dollar profit in 2014.
And the richest person in America once again is Bill Gates.
In March of 2015, the Gates Foundation made its largest investment ever in a single company.
Fifty-two million dollars they plowed into vaccine producer CureVac.
That investment signals that the foundation is moving toward taking stakes and businesses...
...in addition to giving its traditional grants.